it's my pleasure to introduce a
world-renowned scholar whose work would
be recognized in hundreds of countries
across the world for urban sociology and
then of course Richard is also with us
as well but the person I'm going to
introduce there it's Saskia Sassen back
here whose work you may know
globalization and other areas Saskia and
Richard were married a few years ago
they live in London in a wonderful place
in what Dick described as London's
Tribeca though Saskia's at the
University of Chicago and dick is at NYU
if I had been active in sociology when
they came together a few years ago I
would have gone to the Securities
Exchange Commission and filed a
complaint for restriction on trade and
monopolies but they represent an
extraordinarily important and
significant team to many of us now I
assume most of you are here I think
we're all here for about the same reason
we have this tendency in life to keep on
trying to understand maybe that's trying
to understand it's what it's all about
so I have to tell you just one brief
story about my first encounter with dick
Senate and then a long friendship which
is much with too many experiences to go
into as Carlos said in 1970 I ran for
the Senate in Connecticut long time ago
many people came and worked in the
campaign because it was a it was
challenging the ward Vietnam though I
certainly didn't challenge it from a New
Left perspective by any means I was like
Nick mentored by David Richmond took a
different approach but I became very
quite aware of something that was
happening very first of all John Kerry
was a vice chairman of my campaign
Bill Clinton ran the third district many
others many people who thought awed the
Congress but I became aware that we were
unraveling the Democratic Party because
we simply were missing the communication
with a very large group of Americans in
fact that's when I think the left
the Democratic Party began to
disintegrate and it had lot to do with
many things I mean we're opposing a war
but somehow the people supporting it of
course are the people whose sons are
dying there was the cause of the draft
it was like the civil rights movement in
which we were condemning the people or
the busing issue whose really because we
were not in the neighborhoods most of us
where the integration would occur was
that whole thing that began to happen it
was hard to understand I did become
aware of the many young people who came
from all over the country to work with
me that many of them had were all for
civil rights but they really knew no
blacks they were all for the for labor
well up to a point but they didn't know
anybody who'd been active in a labor
union because they had grown up in the
kind of communities that began to emerge
in the 90s and 50s and 60s where they
really lived in quite a better the fact
the one person who had a different
experience of the young people came to
work for me was Bill Clinton because
being raised in Arkansas he actually
knew and had friends and the black
community knew people across a rage of
what we don't really like to call class
I did somebody gave me some research
probably didn't even know about it of
interviews that he was doing about a
book called the hidden injuries of class
in which he described how in a country
in which we deny class there could be
machinists who made more money than
teachers and yet who internally had a
problem with with the self respect the
book was almost a kind of therapy for me
it helped me turn my summit my campaign
into something of a seminar searching to
understand that for the young people to
myself maybe that's why I didn't win the
campaign it became to it but in any
event through those years I have
followed dicks writing I began five
years ago for the first time of my life
maybe as much of an experience as to
learn to try to understand to work in
the business world and I was on an
airplane on my way one of many trips to
Spain with a group of young MBAs with
who
I worked when I read a book called the
corrosion of character and it had an
awful lot of me in fact I got many of my
young people I knew he had never read
anything else to to read that and we
began to talk about it a year ago in the
Financial Times
I read comment a very meaningful comment
about dicks latest book called respect
hasn't been reviewed that often in the
United States but it's an
extraordinarily important book he has
found now and a word and used in a way
to help us understand something about
the world it's for that reason that
after a experience we visit we had in
London I urged him to come here on his
way to Yale to give some lectures next
week and asked Carly if it might be
possible for him to spend some time with
us Richard thank you
well I'm delighted come and talk to you
although I'm not really going to talk
and I've I've I've been released from
having to read from my book which is
people what people usually do I thought
what it might say to you is just
something about this a book is a real
departure for for me because it's it's
autobiographical as well as a work of
social thought and I thought I might
tell you since I don't know you and you
don't know me something about the
autobiographical impulse that moved me
to write this book I had a very unusual
upbringing in that I grew up in a public
housing project in Chicago that was
almost entirely black and I was one of
the few whites in this project the
project called Cabrini Green an infamous
today housing project very little of it
remains standing in my youth it's just
much longer ago
I'd like to think in the late 40s and
early 50s it was simply a place where
poor people who couldn't afford the
commercial housing market went to live
in Chicago and it's funny I don't know
for those of you who my age or older you
probably have found this as well the
things that you think you've just
absolutely forgotten from your childhood
turn out in your 50s to begin to be much
more important to you than you ever
thought they would be in your 20s or 30s
and about five years ago I sort of woke
up to the fact that many of the themes
in my writing is as social sociologists
and social philosopher actually had
something to do with my own experience
in particular with growing up in this
housing project a young white child in a
mostly black black world and I suppose
what I took from it's hard to describe
to you I spent a lot of time trying to
write down what this project felt like
to us there was a great deal of racial
tension but it was an era in which as it
were all the sort of moves about what
racial tension would be for whites and
blacks living together outside the
confines of the old system of
segregation those moves were very
unclear the adults in this community
were overwhelmingly determined to make
integration work and the violence
pent-up violence in black community
against the indignities that
effort from whites came out in the kids
who didn't have a language for
expressing what was inside them it was a
community cabrini-green like much public
housing after the Second World War
which was put together with the best of
intentions it was probably a kind of
model of social engineering
it was the houses were very very simple
we had a wood stove but we there was
internal heat there was internal
plumbing which for many of the blacks
who came up from the south was you know
this was a real move up to actually have
a you know healthful indoor toilets and
running hot water and so on the whites
who were in this project however were
there only because they were poor my
mother was there she was a single parent
she had very little choice she was a
woman of the left and she was constantly
trying to organize the blacks in her
black neighbors in the project to join
various radical causes that's a whole
story I don't go into in this in this
book and failing miserably and this but
basically we were there because we were
we had fallen in to poverty and like
many of the other white families there
the boom after the second world war had
left people like us behind and the first
thing I began to realize when I look
back at this about this experience that
we had was something that has
preoccupied being a lot of my writing
about class since that time and it is
how white working-class people can begin
to use the word them to refer equally
to very poor blacks and to middle-class
well-meaning whites because in this
project and cabrini-green the this model
was something that engineered racial
harmony that really offered something of
great great value to the blacks had
moved up from the south to work there
but offered to the whites no space to be
people on their own right they were
there most of them simply because they
had no other choice
they were failures in the large Society
and the result of failing in the large
Society was that they were condemned to
racial integration and when I began
studying many years later in Boston
white working-class people in the south
of Boston this was during a period when
Boston was going through an explosive
fights over busing racial integration
this memory came back very strongly to
me of this word them how how much
bitterness could be contained in this
notion that there was a kind of unholy
alliance if you like between white
middle class left-wing or liberal people
who could see the sufferings of blacks
but not see the sufferings of white
working-class people and if you buy or
read the book can't say borrow it from
the bookstore but now I try and explain
a little how that feeling of them of
being set upon above and below could
infect the feelings of so many white
working-class people were in themselves
perfectly decent but felt that they were
absolutely invisible and if you like
what could be called a kind of moral
construction of class
in in the US a second big theme in this
book and one I have to say this is a
book that had much more resonance for
foreigners in Europe than its had at
least in this hardcover for Americans
and it may be because of the second
large theme in this book which has to do
with recognizing and respecting people
across the boundaries of inequality as
Americans we are very prone to believe
that people respect each can only
respect each other as equals
that's not something Europeans believe
as much much if you like they're much
more bitter but also more realistic
about the persistence and capitalism
kind of deep rooted inequalities that
attend people's lives from generation to
generation the issue that and I suppose
this as part of my return to Europe that
speaks to them as it speaks to me is
rather than waiting to equalize life
between people in order to practice
mutual respect how can we in an unequal
society find ways to respect those who
are less powerful than we are and
conversely to respect those who are
stronger in some ways not necessarily
economically than ourselves how can we
remove from inequality some of its
characteristic of humiliation and this
is an old old story for a humanist
Italian left at for the British
working-class left that is that we've
got to live in our lives in some way
we're in a very
unequal society people are not
constantly consumed by resentment or
contempt we have to get beyond that and
the question is how do we do that it's
not to accept those inequalities as
inevitable but to say there's another
life project there and that life project
is living with people who are radically
unlike ourselves in power or capacity
this is this is an issue that's
preoccupied me as a social philosopher
for years and years and it's when you
read my book you'll see where I've
gotten at this lake point in my life to
it and it's basically I'm interested in
the way people respect each other's
autonomy rather than respect their
identities and I'm not going to explain
that to you well you'll never have
supper but I will tell you an incident
from Cabrini that as I look back on it
now seems to me to embody this you have
to imagine in the 1950s the poor blacks
as well as poor whites who would grow up
in a housing project like this would not
believe that this was a life long
sentence two remaining poor there's a
lot of hope
in these projects and that hope
continued I would say up until the
middle sixties the project really began
to degrade at the point where the city
of Chicago no longer selected the
tenants that it if you were that is
there it used to be in most public
housing projects you had not to have had
a prison record you needed to be off
drugs and although there was no
requirement that you have intact
families you had to give some sign that
you could be a worthwhile member of the
community
and this changed in the mid-60s housing
projects began parking anyone from them
and they lost a lot of their sense of
self-respect to the projects when but in
my time there were that wasn't a case
and there were people who moved up out
of these projects in to into the working
class lower middle class and a few
people whites as well as blacks who
moved up into the upper middle class in
the book I describe something that as
I've thought about it has come back to
me as a kind of haunting memory of that
movement and what it tells us about this
problem of respect across the boundaries
of inequality there is a group called
cabrini-green heroes and these are
people like myself who heroically have
risen out of poverty into the working
class or middle class or lower middle
class and I used to go back for meetings
in the 60s and early 70s of this group
and I tell you about one of these
meetings we were there as role models
for young kids and one of these meetings
the youngest cabrini-green hero was a
young Porto Rican man who had become an
eye surgeon he was only about 12 years
older than most of the kids these were
meetings aimed at high school students
he was a born-again Christian he had
left of a wife and a girlfriend along
the way in to becoming a doctor and he
spoke at this Cabrini Green heroes
meeting about the process of self
transformation that allowed him to rise
out of poverty was kind of inner self
transformation he should have been
inspiring but in fact
he instilled a profound sense in his
teenage listeners that they were being
dissed disrespected and I puzzled over
that at the time actually things got
quite to the edge of violence I mean
people were shouting at him you know
you're an Oriole that means black on the
outside white on the inside and he would
shout back you strive you're ashamed of
yourself and so on what I realized about
this was that this was an encounter in
which in some way he conveyed a message
to them if I could do it why can't you
and he conveyed that message by saying
that where you stand in society only
depends on how you feel he had this
religious conversion he got Jesus and
the next thing he knew he was in medical
school this couldn't be more humiliating
to these kids because there's no
practice in it right it's all about
subjective feeling there's there's no
way he could have said to them now look
the first step in if you need a
religious conversion in order to learn
science the first step is a B and C you
know so on nor did he actually ever talk
to them about science it was all about
the notion that you and I are just alike
and if you want to change your life all
it takes is a change from within and
that was profoundly humiliating to them
and they were furious at it because
since they weren't changing there was
something deeply wrong with them now the
lesson for that as I've thought back
about it is that he's actually preaching
a kind of very American
version of equality that is that we are
all the same so what sense do you make
of the fact that in I'm an eye doctor
and you're a kid fending off drugs it's
all a lack of motivation and it's a kind
of psychologizing of respect which
leaves people with no sense of how to
behave so in my book I described this
incident and the kind of conundrum it
poses for us in thinking about
inequality it would have been better for
him to have said to these kids you know
something I've got a talent you don't
have I'm an eye surgeon you know and I'm
sorry about that well you know it's this
is an unusual thing I'm gifted in
science we've got to find a way but I'm
from the community I've come back here
I've come back to give something back to
you but we're not the same there would
have been a more mutual irrespective
that would have been to show more
respect to them then the kind of notion
which I think has infected American
left-wing discourse certainly about
respect which is that inequality is
something that is necessary for people
in order to respect each other and that
in quality is basically made into a kind
of psychological state that you can
become whoever or whatever you want and
if you don't it's your own fault
I found this years and years later in
interviewing workers in the 90s who had
been let go from corporations that
downsized resized re-engineered and so
on who tended to blame themselves rather
than say this is a structure beyond my
control that has middle-aged
workers that has you know sent me out of
the labor market and it's that and of
course they lost a great deal of respect
for themselves you know because it was
their fault something like that I'm told
happened in the Great Depression that
lots of workers who lost their jobs felt
this is something I did wrong so I tell
you this very convoluted story because
it's something I try to make sense of in
this book this is a book of sociology
that is about what kind of practices
people need to engage in to feel
respected or to show respect to those
who differ from themselves and it deals
with a very complicated issue that is
parts of the experience of inequality
people have are things like inequality
of ability is in the case of this young
eye surgeon differences between children
and adults are also a kind of inequality
children don't have the understanding
either emotional or in or rational of
adults all sorts of other kinds of
inequalities we can think of between the
middle-aged and the elderly the notion
that we have to somehow find an equal
plane a common set of understandings in
order in all of these cases to show
respect and feel respect seems to me a
doomed project and my book is an attempt
to look at the alternatives to this very
American way of thinking about what how
respect is actually experienced in
people's lives well I'm sorry I didn't
mean to go on for such a long time about
about this this was a very it's just
I've interviewed many many people in my
life I this is the first time I've
really interviewed myself for public
consumption it was it is the most
horrible experience I've had Azra as a
writer I don't like confessional
literature very much I love listening to
other people's stories but I'm sure
there's some deep psychological flawed
me but my own story act I tend to keep
to myself but I have it's a kind of
experiment in this book to see for what
this peculiar situation that I grew up
in and it's being a white child in a
black housing project to just understand
what what kinds of issues that raises
which neither about whites or blacks
necessarily but about the conditions of
inequality and mutual respect in modern
society we need we have an audience mic
in the middle of the room and we really
need people to use that especially
because our friends all over the United
States will be seeing this through
c-span so I think it's great that Joe
will start and it like him if you don't
mind Joe to come up here so that
everyone can hear unlike any other
questions you ought to be asked I'm
going to abstract from this and go way
up and you may not want to go there
you take the term respect and you take
the term self-respect in a sense respect
engenders self-respect creates the
possibility and you talk about
humiliation is it are there reflections
to be made in the larger canvas about
the gulf between the west and Islam
I've absolutely no idea I mean am I
supposed am I supposed to know about
this let me do the time-honored thing
and answer another question than the one
you asked is that all right I really
don't know about this which is what do
we mean when we use the word respect we
can mean many things by it sometimes we
mean you know envy you know you just you
know the notion that you respect
somebody who's got more money than you
is a kind of rather envious formulation
sometimes we mean honor an honor is
maybe this actually is an answer to your
question although I know nothing about
Islam honor is a very peculiar form of
respect and it's something that I think
is absent in many American communities
because honor is a kind of mutual
respect that comes from the observance
of law to give you an example of
actually give you an example from the
Quran maybe I can answer your question
which is that every believing Muslim has
to contribute 10% of their income to the
community a failure to make that
contribution nothing will happen to you
except that you will lose honor nobody's
going to punish you you're not going to
you're not going to be smoked dead it's
not a sin but it is a failure to
participate in the norms of a community
and if you fail in that you feel a sense
of being Dishonored what we have
our instead codes of quote-unquote
earning respect which is very different
from honor you know to earn respect
means you do something that arouses in
the eyes of other people the sense that
you stand out as an individual you know
that's I think the American formula for
it but standing out as an individual
means you stand out from a community you
sever yourself from the community and I
think we need more honor in the society
and less earning of respect that's the
that's the argument that I make in this
book to do that we need kinds of
community which are about practices in
which people have reciprocal obligations
to each other not that they feel good
about each other but that they feel
bound to each other there's a German
word for this which i think is a very
very good german phrase for it which is
called Bindoon ona Gemeinschaft and what
that means is glue without intimacy
without identity without face-to-face
warmth it's that if you live in a
community you are responsible to other
members of it no matter whether they're
stronger or weaker than you are and
that's not something we know very much
in the u.s. right this is half an answer
to question your reference to
cabrini-green Housing that became so
well known for supposedly a model for
low-cost housing could you elaborate a
little bit on its failures yes
there's an easy way to account its
failures and then there's the way the
residents are counted which is much more
complicated the easy way to account its
failures was that it was all the fault
of the this of the government of the
Chicago Housing Authority dumped all
these drug addicts and into the
community it stopped keeping the project
up it added to what was a set of
low-rise structures began building very
very high towers Robert Taylor homes
which were embodied all the vices of you
know a social housing and so on and
that's a usual story you get about it
that it that is that it was the
government's felt the story in the
community is is that story plus
something else which was that there was
a breakdown and this is what I am told
by by people who remained that there was
a breakdown in the community in that
when people left it they didn't move
just a little bit they got as far away
from it as they could be that is that
they were abandoned by anyone who could
get out and that is a story told both
about whites and about blacks it's a
fairly intergenerational story that that
I mean it's mostly an intergenerational
story though if the children could leave
what they wouldn't do is stay within
walking distance the community and
symbolically
they wouldn't remain attached to it but
that there was a kind of continual
process of shedding and abandonment
going on and as a lot of recrimination
about that about the people who were who
were who were outing which
meant that they were simply walking away
from their past so I mean the city
behaved despicably the first mayor Daly
was appalling you know these these were
these were to him he was as bad as any
southern racist but it's true of most
very poor communities that people you
know this art was our life you know we
weren't just a social statistic and that
there wasn't enough there wasn't enough
social bond between particularly between
generations that people had that kind of
continuity this had a particular kind of
twist for us who were the cabrini-green
heroes because it was only the
successful ones who were coming back who
were staying in contact with the
community you know this was this was not
good so this as I said there are two
very different stories about how how
this place went downhill there is a
great tendency to romance most housing
projects and you make a lot of money in
popular culture off of romancing them
now when I lived there was not a
dangerous place you know because there
were no drugs I mean the crimes of
choice were numbers rackets and drinking
which was with very few guns so it was
not there was random violence but there
was nothing like what was later but
there is a terrible tendency to make a
romance out of these places and I think
Cabrini has become in particular a kind
of emblem for you know on the one hand
you know tough you know life in the hood
it seems very sexy in another way
it is saying you know these aren't
people who are human they're not like us
look how different they are you know and
worse
yes it went it went to such worse that
it was taken down the Robert Taylor
homes like pruitt-igoe do you know what
that is in st. Louis the the last thing
you can do in housing projects with poor
people is make these housing projects
vertical in order to have the street
life and life outside the house work in
some way there has to be what Jane
Jacobs called eyes on the street there's
got to you've got to be very close to
the outside in order you know most
criminals like peace and quiet in order
to get on with it you know and the turn
into that kind of high-rise housing was
you know a disaster but all I'm saying
to you about this is that it is a
mistake you take away the agency of
people as people who are living there by
saying this is merely you know
government gone wrong it was that but
there was also a feeling of kind of
mutual betrayal across the generations
and that's very important to to
recognize about this that is the human
elements in how people live under
adverse conditions like this sorry big
very long-winded I actually came here to
listen to the man who thirty years ago
wrote the fall of the public man oh yeah
well that's another subject yeah it's no
I don't actually think so as the
finished journalist I've covered the
Russia have covered I tried to cover
this strange country and I'm very
concerned about what I experienced as
disintegration of civil society here yes
yes and I without having read that book
I have a feeling that respect your
understanding of respect and this
integration of civil society is actually
something which is in one piece more or
less could you elaborate
it's nice simple question well all I can
say to you about this
it'll be very brief about this is simply
that you can use experience as a mutual
respect as a kind of barometer or a
thermometer to know how how cohesive a
civil society is you can't have a civil
society you can indeed you can't have as
a civil state in which there is in some
attempt to bridge inequality by rituals
and codes of mutual recognition you
can't do it and I'm interested that you
have that sense that this is a
collapsing social order most Europeans
have that about the US and it's not anti
Americanism it's something else it's
that it looks and the European and me
would say the same thing that you're
losing you're glue you're losing your
bin do you know and that repression you
know a patriot act is not going to glue
people back together but maybe we
shouldn't get into that lower why not go
ahead please maybe we should yeah my
question in a way follows up on this at
a much more practical level um I started
reading your book as part of an effort
to understand my neighborhood I live in
a pretty diverse neighborhood in DC and
I think it's fair to say we experience a
lot of inequality I mean just to give
you an idea of some of the sectors we
have a lot of Latino immigrants in my
neighborhood a lot of african-american
families a lot of white families a lot
of young professionals coming in like
myself and I get the sense it's just
being in the neighborhood there's a
large differential and the kinds of
businesses in the neighborhood different
sectors actually use and how people
interact and who comes to community
meetings and you know who even has
internet access to know about online
forums about the neighborhood there's
there's a lot of divides and
I wonder I also think that there are a
lot of different perceptions about how
people in different groups think that
other groups perceive them and I wonder
if you know using respect as a model
what are some of the steps we could take
to help across some of those divides
using what you've learned well this is
an answer I also have to direct at this
is your Commissioner of planning for BC
here so maybe we have a dis light
discussion about about this he actually
can do something about it one of the
things I've been thinking about a lot
about this is how do you actually we
have lots of difference in American
cities and very very diverse there's
lots of difference but there's lots of
indifference at the same time
diversities that don't interact and that
is it's a real planning conundrum I mean
how do you mobilize this kind of
diversity and you could look at this in
- in planning terms in two ways one
would be that you try and create
community you know centers for
communities where people sort of you
know where everything moves towards the
center and get very you got a like a
high street in a in a British town or or
a town center in Europe I my own sense
is that that's an old model that's
exhausted and that what we need to look
R at are the edge conditions between
different communities even if there are
parts of a street you know how do you
get at the point at which say there are
six Salvadorian families living next to
three white Irish families how do you
make just the physical and social edge
between them something that's alive
rather than a point of separation and
it's a very as Andrew will tell is a
very complicated thing particularly when
you try and do large-scale urban design
it poses some real
it you know poses some real cultural
questions but also some very practical
questions if it's this fine grain of
encountering difference and dealing with
difference that matters then the less
communal identity places have the more
opportunity you have for that the more
that you sector eyes a community and say
well this is a section reserved for
people of such-and-such an income and
this is place for people with
such-and-such an income the less likely
that kind of grain is to occur let me
just give you an example that of the way
in which the Netherlands deals with
housing for poor people which contrasts
to our mindset in the Netherlands if
you're a poor person and you need income
support for housing you get this
anonymously from the state and so you
can go out and rent a flat at an
apartment and your neighbors need never
know that your own income support there
is no sector is a ssin of that this is a
brilliant plan for a certain kind of
social integration it's broken down with
the advent of lots of Moroccan
immigrants in into the Netherlands but
as concerns people who aren't visibly
different or simply of a different class
it's a brilliant way of creating that
kind of community with its very small
engines we don't do that we think in
types and now so many blacks have to be
in some you know in a school here to
integrate it we think in numbers and I
to me the the notion of how to make this
work at a communal level is to fragment
as much as we can find ways to enable
people to live more and personally in a
more fragmented condition with their
neighbors rather than strengthening the
community is
Center you know that's why this you know
the Gemeinschaft part of it I think is
is the wrong way to do this so there's a
very very long answer but this is
something we've been talking about a lot
because when you do large-scale planning
that's your problem you can't say okay
the cocktail shaker is going you know
you know you've got a staff got you know
I'm going to give 16 thousand units of
housing and five thousand was this five
thousand going to be like that and you
begin this kind of sector Isaac but
that's my own recipe for how to do this
which is to think more Dutch about about
this give people more anonymity that's
so I take one more question than when I
think of you know I'm getting old to
questions thank you or one question this
is a question about respect in an
international scale one thing I did not
learn in school was that just about
every country if not every country in
the world that has given the
industrialized West a hard time in the
last 50 or 60 years as at one time or
another been invaded compromised cooed
or whatever by the industrialized world
last 150 years and I think that they
really feel violated they really feel a
lack of respect how can we bring respect
to the international conversation thank
you well you know what I would say to
you about this I thought what I thought
about this you know I'm no policy expert
but what I've thought about this is the
story I told you about this eye surgeon
is also a story about America you know
if I can do it why can't you do it
here's a market which is the equivalent
of a kind of religious transformation
it's the Jeffrey Sachs model of you know
of this here's a market you know it's a
new faith if we got rich what's wrong
with you
for if I just pick up on your question a
bit when for Saskia and I well we've had
discussions with people the year after
in Britain and and the year after the
September 11th attacks you could see in
the course of that year people's
enormous sympathy for the US just erode
and the reason for that was the Bush
administration's using what was a
tragedy right of that that that
destroyed so many thousand the lives of
70,000 people is another weapon in this
American notion of you know we are
basically in control and what we want
goes and I mean they feel dissed and
they felt as you say they felt dissed
for a very long time is that
anti-americanism
I don't know wouldn't you be angry if
you'd been treated you know for a decade
after decade is not good enough you know
what do you know it's as though it's I
mean the Iraq in Europe the Iraq war has
been a way for people to let out from
themselves particularly ordinary people
I'm not talking about left you know
left-wing intellectuals ordinary people
to let out of the bottle the feeling
that Americans practice disrespect on
them you know through the ideology of
here it is anybody could be like us you
know and we're of course there's you
know the model of how you should be and
it's it's a very over determined
reaction and the feeling is is it
anti-american or is it a feeling like
you
no how dare you you know and as I say
that's not so far off from the way
there's kids in the community center
reacted to this young doctor I saw how
the Canadians did it as far as the
housing is concerned I went with my
girlfriend who is a professor of
political science at the University of
Philippines and her husband as a head of
the department there to visit sister to
visit a sister and her her husband and
nephew and his wife in Toronto area in
Toronto and they the the amount they are
charged for department now they had a
gov inherited apartment which is one
bedroom and the amount they were charged
went up and down according to what they
earned now the there were an elderly
couple and the father husband had been
working but then he had a stroke so they
reduced the amount of the rent and then
the wife had been working and she she
was a petite little thing and working in
a nursing home is she got hurt or back
so so became less again it became less
and then the husband was going to so it
was reduced and then the husband was
going to forgetting your retirement so
then again the rent would be going up so
they this is the way they dealt with it
I was just amazed at and the people
respected the government it was the most
amazing thing and the nephew came to
Canada well look what I would say to you
about this is you know that if you if
you're an institution that figures out a
way to treat people with respect by not
singling them out as something wrong
with them when they need help then they
will respect you as an institution this
is something I'm sorry to cut you off
but there's a section of my book about
about the relation between how
compassion degrades into pitying and
contempt in bureaucracies that deal with
the welfare state it was a huge issue
for us in cabrini-green but I think
it's a general problem in how we design
government policies that deal with
people respectfully without singling
them out as people who are worthy of
pity and we're not so good at that the
Canadians are good at it
the Dutch are good at it so are the
Scandinavians that need is not the
occasion for feeling pity about someone
else this is not an original idea to me
I'm sure you've got a lot of Hannah
Arendt here and she made a famous
statement which could have I didn't need
to write the book but because it says it
all which is a foundation of the social
order is comradeship not compassion
that's a good
and with that I'd leave you thank you
very much
which eternal of exciting or something